je déclare donc monsieur fourgous
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
mon courage avant un nouveau mandat de
six ans pour le maire les républicains
d'elancourt pour ce conseil
d'agglomération de la mandature 2020
2026 jean michel fourgous était seul
candidat à sa succession
une présidence qu'il place sous le signe
de l'emploi et des entreprises pour
répondre à la crise sociale
notre enjeu prioritaire sera l'emploi
bien sûr et la sauvegarde de notre tissu
économique et du niveau de vie de nos
douze commun c'est notre devoir d'élus
locaux d'aider les jeunes français à
entrer aussi sur le marché du travail
ça va être un moment difficile nous ne
devons pas avoir une génération
sacrifiée une élection aussi pour quinze
vice-présidents comme en 2017 jean
michel fourgous a choisi de donner des
délégations aux quatre maires de gauche
françois morton édile de guyancourt et
nouvel élu communautaire hérite de la
politique de la ville de la santé et des
solidarités
je pense que c'est important la
politique de la ville je la connais bien
je la pratique au niveau de vie en cours
depuis maintenant presque la totalité du
mandat puisque j'ai été élu à la
politique de la ville et la santé est
évidemment un enjeu primordial
après la période que nous venons de
ville vivre et les solidarités c'est
l'adn de la ville de guyancourt nouveaux
conseillers aussi lorrain merker qui est
en charge de l'urbanisme et de
l'aménagement du territoire
il devient aussi le premier vice
président de l'agglomération
ce que je veux retenir surtout moi ce
matin c'est la cohésion qui a eu au
niveau de tous les élus un grand sens
des responsabilités de chacun et je
trouve ça très encourageant est très
enthousiasmant pour les six années à
venir
et le fait de voir tous les élus quels
que soient leurs bords qui souhaitent
travailler ensemble de cette manière
je pense qu'on va pouvoir bien bien
travailler pendant ses six années
l'environnement et la transition
écologique thèmes forts de la dernière
campagne des municipales sont confiés à
la mère de plaisir joséphine coleman
bergès l'environnement en tant que tel
fait partie de quelque chose de
transversale on va le retrouver
absolument partout j'ai déjà évoqué avec
certains vices présidents cette
nécessité de travailler ensemble que ce
soit sur l'habitat que ce soit même dans
les commerces dans le développement
économique
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus inscrire un
développement économique sans tenir
compte de l'environnement jean michel
fourgous a prévenu les conseillers
communautaires ce mandat sera celui du
rassemblement face aux difficultés
sanitaires et économiques
parmi les gros projets à la charge de
l'agglomération l'accueil de plusieurs
épreuves sportives lors des jeux
olympiques de 2024